we want to do science it's fascinating
but it's even more rewarding if it's for
the benefit of society if you can see
civilization improving that's fantastic
[Music]
we made this discoveries
early 1970s essentially we realize that
these chemicals would have a very strong
environmental impact because they would
affect the ozone layer it's been
exciting for all of us here at the
university to be involved in this great
event with the nobel prize inspiration
initiative we were able to come up with
a an international agreement all the
countries in the planet agreed not to
manufacture CFCs anymore the nobel prize
inspiration initiative has been
fantastic with 3m we started the day
with a presentation by mario on climate
change in a good discussion we were able
to engage students from local
universities and the area colleges we
know how to solve many of those
challenges and it's truly an issue of
politics economics money and power and
maybe the grand challenge is to you know
define more Grand Challenges you know is
humanity really as good as it could be
maybe our human potential hasn't really
been reached properly how do you go
about communicating problems that aren't
real to a non-scientist we should make a
special effort to first change the mind
of those that are in power that's an
incredibly inspiring and incredibly
great message to be able to talk about
how science can help you drive to social
change
often times we as students don't know
how we can impact the world very
important thing is to understand the
scientific method make decisions based
on evidence and not just on beliefs it's
our responsibility to live a world for
future generations in which they can
have a standard of
at least as good as the one we have
today many of our students we hear from
them every day they are concerned about
the future and what they can do we don't
need to sacrifice economic growth
technology has advanced to such a degree
that now these forms of energy wind and
solar are competitive when you have
someone who says we do have the
solutions we just have to take action on
them I think that inspires students to
to take action you can argue and say oh
civilization will advance no matter what
no bit what happened by itself we need
to be there we need to work all together
and I think we can do it
[Music]